Pablo Larraín is an
incredible creative mind.
Pablo is such an artist.
He's a visionary.
I come from the world of cinema,
where things are condensed to two hours.
Here the invitation was to do
an eight-hour episodic television show.
Stephen King is someone
who's been able to
understand our humanity
in a very universal way.
The last 50 years of our culture
have been somehow shaped
by his stories.
I went to Maine, and I stayed
at Stephen King's house,
which was a very fascinating experience.
Reading and kind of
going over the scripts,
trying for me to understand
what he really was looking for,
that maybe was not exactly on the page.
I personally struggled in the beginning.
I wanted to take everything
to a more grounded sort of space,
where the narrative was more
naturalistic or realistic.
And he was like,
"No, you have to come to my world,
where all the things happen
to the characters.
They do travel to different worlds
and different realities."
So I had to go, as a filmmaker,
through a process
of embrace that narrative.
And it's funny, because it's somehow
what happens to
the main character as well.
Lisey's Story is a story of a woman
who is trying to put herself together,
to move on with her life.
Lisey doesn't want to admit
that that world exists,
or that
that kind of things can happen.
It's wonderful for me as a filmmaker,
because you have to find a way
to create certain layers
of a narrative that is placed
in this fragmented memory.
Memories combine and mix with fantasy.
And that fantasy goes into
the real world, and vice versa.
It was just a fascinating process,
to embrace the fantasies
and the psychological horror
in a way that has
some poetry and some beauty.
This journey of humanity
will take us to
pain, sorrow, beauty, family, love...
a lot of darkness,
and a lot of light and healing.
The experience of doing this,
it really changed me and
made me a different filmmaker.
So I'm very grateful.
Why are they so important to you?
Because stories are all I have.